did you get in a fight or something oh
hi thank you
got into an altercation proof say johnny
depp's lawyers that amber heard attacked
her sister
i can't believe amber beat your ass an
aired reality tv footage sees whitney
henrique repeatedly avoid questions
about a fight
okay did you really start the fight with
your sister or did she start it for real
for real for real
we're not gonna talk about that she
really did whoop your butt
mr depp's legal team say it shows her
with marks to her chest and arm
they accused ms henriquez of lying in
her evidence the day before
when she said amber heard had never been
violent towards her
the video was released anonymously late
thursday evening to johnny depp's
lawyers
he's suing the publishers of the sun
newspaper over an article describing him
as a wife beater
the footage is crucial mr depp's legal
team say because they're arguing that
amber heard was the violent one during
the couple's relationship
miss heard's sister says that their
fight was just verbal that the show's
producers were trying to create a
storyline and that mr depp's lawyers
were looking for injuries that weren't
there
whitney henriquez denied giving false
evidence and said
i'm here because she was a victim of
domestic violence for no other reason
i'm here to tell the truth and to do the
right thing
in court friends of amber heard also
backed up her claims
she told one of them mr depp would
rather destroy her than let her leave
all evidence has now finished with
speeches from both sides next week then
it will be up to a judge to decide with
hollywood reputations
potentially on the line adele robinson
sky news at the high court